Bobby right yeah cap I can't yep okay
kitty cat you would pet I've seen you in
detention
oh that's right maybe up the parka for
thank you wish you had horns that would
be so sweet God and if them do like
pissing you off you'd stab him I've seen
you in science class you sit right near
the window in the Sun yeah I get so hot
in that class I make my skin burn no
you're so pale sometimes I just want to
wrap a black baby bun blanket around to
you I wish you would do that in the
middle of class I'd like it is this a
date no what do you think is yeah I'd
prefer if we didn't put labels on
anything for now right yeah
know who I hate I know you're gonna say
alright count of three say it one two
three
pretty simple mark I know I hate it cuz
he always stops me in the hallway and
says good stand up straight
show me your tits I know exactly what
you think he coming to music Bobby put a
smile on your face stop frowning all the
time I can't stand it anymore
I wanna smile that's not the person you
are if I saw him in the mall we got
totally punch him in the face even if he
was with it's a family I'd punch him so
hard you know who else I hate state a
she's just a [ __ ] 24/7 she's always
telling me cat you're so weird what's
wrong with you my time with Delia
cheerleading [ __ ] well she could follow
into cheer leads and break her neck I'd
give her a round of applause I ate
popcorn I'd left so hard if you did that
last time I was here I buried a letter
to my future self can you read it to me
you know Harris dear future cat is a
whole world still shitty I bet it is
I sold a big bug today are there still
bugs in the future I hope so they
understand me the most
oh hello what address is this it's me I
made it I drew it for you
Bobby it's totally not a big deal you
only took me like three days how are we
Cal hey love you
okay if you guys are curious as to why
this guy is here it's because he's in
the alternate ending of the sketch on
bad weather films check out their
channel that's hilarious
subscribe thanks for watching guys